maybe a time period when you don't know
exactly what to do with your so-called
life which is not yours so you just be
as still as possible do your whatever
activity you're already doing and but
bring Stillness into it and then at some
point either the realization of what it
is that you need to do that wants to be
done through you and then you start
taking action always making sure you're
not so attached to the outcome that you
think it's more important than the
present moment an action can become
egoic when you lose yourself in the
doing and a good sign or good Criterion
when something happens against your
seems to be an obstacle a person or
situation say I want to do this or
achieve that and suddenly somebody says
no you can't do that or situation
becomes a challenge it's difficult it's
blocked you want to go someone says no
you you're not qualified to do that you
shouldn't do that it's not allowed
obstacles come all the time if you get
upset that means the ego is back in the
doing when obstacles come hey S car
Michael and I make these videos because
I need them from me because I want to
wake up every day and watch a video that
puts me in a mindset to believe in
myself more and go off and accomplish
amazing things and attack the day and I
hope that this video does that for you
as well so today let's learn how to
unlock your power to manifest
enjoy if you're not upset you're still
present and you look at whatever the
obstacle is very and you look at it with
this penetrating gaze of
presence which is stillness also you
look at whatever this the obstacle
arises you bring this
penetrating Stillness to it and that is
like a light shines on
it and
then that dissolves the obstacle or it
shows you way around
it
That's The Power Of
Consciousness it always happens either
it shows you how to get around it or it
shows you how to use the very force of
the
obstacle and you turn it around if the
obstacle is going to to go this way and
you go with it for I'm just
demonstrating now something counteracts
what you want to do it's coming this way
you want to go that way but you don't me
it head on and start complaining say
this shouldn't be
happening no perhaps you go with it for
a little while and you
go and then you turn it
around and the Very power that was
against
you then works for you and you achieve
your goal through that it happens and
this is the wisdom that comes with
non-resistance so whenever you go into
this conscious doing
resistance always pulls you back into
unconscious doing can easily happen
because it's an old habit pattern
unconscious doing inner resistance to
whatever arises in the present moment
pulls you back inner resistance is some
form of negativity some form of
complaining some form of uh fear uh
aggression
anger and this is important because
whenever you complain about what
somebody else does that you're already
beginning to fall into that trap of
unconsciousness don't judge yourself if
you fall back occasionally into the old
Consciousness but you will quickly know
it how will you know
it you begin to
suffer you get
upset you get UPS upset about situations
you get upset about people you get upset
about what somebody said you get upset
about what somebody should have said but
didn't you get upset about what somebody
did or failed to
do oh there's a sign that you've Fallen
back beautiful line in the CA in
Miracles I am never upset for the reason
I think so you'll be upset many times
every
day by other people by situations by the
slightest things or the biggest things
upset upset upset by the entire world is
so
frustrating I'm never so that's a little
sign then if you're upset you want to go
somewhere but but people are not
Cooperative situations are not
cooperative
and you can talk to
[Laughter]
yourself so that's a good sign then you
can use also shows you to what
extent the ego is active in you because
what's upset is not you it's the ego in
you the ego is the erroneous
identification with
form a false sense of of
eye uh which wanted something to make
itself
feel more at ease or bigger or more
important or whatever and is frustrated
in its aims how much
doing
you do how much varies from form to form
person to
person some will be very active and
conscious into conscious doing and
create and and enjoy the
creation and others may do relatively
little or may just continue to do what
they're doing already but whatever they
are doing will be a vehicle for
Consciousness or Stillness that flows
into it this
power this beautiful energy that flows
it could be even a person who just gives
information
let's say you work at an airport and you
give information to
people and maybe you stay there and then
everybody who comes to ask where's gate
number 16 you say
well you go that way and it's only about
a 3 minute
walk and there were not only the
words there was a transmission of still
with the words not in the sense that I
am going to transmit Stillness
no it it happens because you let go of
the sense of doing of I do it
happens and the person this one
traditional word for it is blessing the
person goes away being blessed with that
energy and
so beautiful so so what you do really
is secondary some may do great
things Others May do things that look on
the
surface not so
significant and
ultimately what you
do is
secondary but how you do it is primary
when the how
means the Consciousness that flows into
what you do number two is don't let your
mind limit you with Bruce Lipton the
problem with the concept of power the
power of positive thinking is people
just think oh well if I just have
positive thoughts then my life should be
affected and and this is why positive
thinking has a real bad rap in the
public and the reason is this having a
positive thought does not in any way
necessitate that those positive thoughts
actually manifest themselves and there's
a piece that was left out and if you
don't understand the peace then you're
shouting into the wind with your
positive thoughts nothing's going to
happen and the fact is this
when you're having positive thoughts
you're using your mind the new biology
reveals that the invisible forces that
collectively we refer to as mind that
these form a field which shape
biology well here's what's important yes
the Mind influences biology but there
are two parts to the mind that are
completely different than one another
yet they work together we confuse them
we tie them together and yet they
represent two entities working in two
different fashion passions there's the
conscious mind and what is called the
subconscious mind now here's what the
very important people have to know this
okay and here's what it is the conscious
mind is our creative mind that is
connected to our personal identity and
our spiritual selves that's that makes
us all unique each of us has our own
personal conscious mind but what becomes
very significant is this is a
subconscious mind is equivalent to a
tape player it's exactly what it is it
records experiences and then plays them
back and and so now let's take a look
and say well wait there's a thinking
mind and then there's a tape player mind
and what's different about them is very
profound so let's talk about two
fundamental differences first the tape
player the subconscious mind as an
information processor as the equivalent
of a computer is a million times more
powerful an information processor than
is the conscious mind so when you look
at the power between the conscious and
subconscious subconscious is a million
times more powerful number
two on a day byday basis the
subconscious mind runs our biology about
95 to 99% of the time so while you're
having all these wonderful thoughts
that's not the conscious the conscious
mind is not running the show it's a
subconscious mind then comes the issue
is well the subconscious mind got
programs in it yes and the and and the
subconscious mind is not evil or good
the subconscious mind is a tape player
as much as you can say okay here here's
a tape player it's good or bad it's not
the tap player is not good or bad the
programs can be good and the programs
can be bad so blaming the subconscious
mind as a negative thing is that's the
first mistake it's a tape player the
programs that we got that's the source
of the problems that most of us face and
that these programs could limit our
abilities and take away our powers which
is essentially they do now the relevance
about positive thinking is
this positive thinking is a creative
thought that comes from the conscious
mind okay so I sit here and I'm going to
have all these wonderful thoughts I'm
going to close my eyes and visualize all
these wonderful things now stop and go
back to to the the mechanical character
of it a I'm having these thoughts with a
little tiny processor called the
conscious mind and I'm competing with
the programs that are in the
subconscious mine so if I have a thought
for uh being being healthy or being in a
good
relationship and I'm doing positive
thinking and at the same time I have
acquired programs in my development that
said you're not as healthy as you think
you are and you you're not that good a
person to have those kind of
relationships then look I'm now pitting
my positive thoughts against my programs
and and they're and they're
opposite but this one works on a little
tiny processor and this processor is a
million times more powerful so right
away it's like who's going to win in
that challenge the answer of course the
subconscious is going to win okay but
here comes the other
part well I can try to maintain positive
thoughts in my life using my conscious
mind this conscious mind only operates
less than 5% of the day that says 95% or
more of the day I'm operating from the
other belief system the point is do the
math how powerful are positive thoughts
and the answer is unless the
subconscious has the same program an
agreement as a conscious mind power of
positive thinking will not work it will
not work because you're competing
against a much more powerful processor
the belief that is taught is that
biology in the world we live in operates
according to Newtonian principles uh
unfortunate part about that is quantum
mechanics 100 years ago said that's
obviously not true and physicists know
this is not true and yet medicine
doesn't buy into it because it still
focuses on the material reality and lets
go of the invisible shaping fields that
quantum physics emphasizes as primary
okay so we got we have to change that
belief system we have to get people to
recognize that the field and the
thoughts and all these other things are
as important as anything else in shaping
the matter we live in uh number two uh
the belief which you know I blew away
years ago but it's still being taught in
school is the concept that genes control
life this is totally false genes control
nothing control is an action a gene is a
blueprint it's a physically literally a
string with blueprint data on it what
why is that relevant it's interesting go
to an architect's office and the
architect's working on a blueprint and
then lean over the architect's shoulder
and say is that blueprint on or off and
he looks at you a blueprint is not on or
off it's a blueprint yeah but we talk
about genes being on and off like genes
are turn turning on and genes are
turning off and the question is but
jeans are blueprints they can't turn on
and off there is no on and off it's just
the blueprint it's a pattern what we
have failed to focus on because we gave
genes a character of
self-actualization that my genes decided
to do something it's like okay now we're
a victim of the genes but it turns out
biologists know that this is not true
biologists know that genes are not
turned on and off genes are red or not
red like blueprints then all of a sudden
it says well it's not the blueprint
that's important if the blueprints were
self-actualizing an architect could go
by building site drop the blueprints off
come back two weeks later and the
building will be there that's what we
think about animals and plants the genes
are Blueprints and they'll control all
this it's like no the blueprints are
important I'm not saying they're not you
got the bad blueprints you got some
problems going on here but the issue is
it's not the presence or absence of a
blueprint it's whether the blueprint is
being read and then you say well then
who reads the blueprint and the answer
is a contractor and who's the contractor
the m mind is the contractor the Mind
reads genes the mind can change the
genes readout here here's something so
blow away that most people can't in
their conventional World make sense of
it because it's it's like ah goes like
this the Mind through what is called
epigenetic
mechanisms can start with a single Gene
blueprint and create over
30,000 different versions of products
from the same blueprint 30,000 different
products from the same blueprint all of
a sudden you realize my God you can
infinitely vary the expression of the
Gene and the answer is yes and why is
this become relevant to all of us and
the answer is because many of us think
genes control our lives and yet we don't
realize that we modify the Reed out of
the gene so we could be totally healthy
and our mind can cause cancer our mind
can cause any disease diabetes anything
like that and and what's interesting is
the flip side is some people come here
with actually defective genes and guess
what with their mind they can rewrite
those genes and make them normal so the
genes are not the limiting factor it's
the Mind hi I'm Bruce lion author of the
bestselling books the biology belief
spontaneous Evolution and the honeymoon
effect I'm here to thank Evan carmichel
for featuring me on his YouTube channel
and I want to let you know that Evan is
giving away links where you can watch
the First episodes of my special guy
series entitled in a revolution for free
evid is making this offer to thank you
for watching this video you will find
the links in the description section
below thank you rule number three is
restructure your brain with Joe despenza
I have worked so hard in getting people
to the point where they can forget about
themselves and become nobody no one no
thing nowhere and no
time people when they finally get this
when they finally realize that when
they're they're that they pure
Consciousness and they're connected to
the field and then they start putting
their attention on that frequency of
Oneness and wholeness and tune into it
and pay attention to it and stay present
with it and become more aware of it and
experience it and feel it moment after
moment after
moment how many how much of people's
waking day do they put their attention
on the field and how much do they put
their attention on matter I'd say 100%
of the time they put their attention on
matter now my students are connecting to
a greater frequency they know how to get
Beyond themselves they can sit for
extended periods of time they could lock
in they can experience it I
watch if they're connecting to that
level of frequency called the quantum
field where they're experiencing
something cool something greater that
you can't experience with your senses as
you evolve and unfold deeper into it you
experience less separation and more
Oneness and wholeness and the more
connected you are to it the less
distance between you as a
Consciousness free willed individual and
the consciousness of the objective
unified field the closer you are to it
the shorter amount of time it's going to
take for it to appear in your life
because you're outside of you're out
outside the fundamental rules of
Newtonian physics and 3D reality you're
you're changing the field and it changes
matter
instantaneously so now we're seeing it
happen in a shorter amount of time
because we're getting better at it we're
connecting to that field more and I know
this to be the case because when I
witness it in week-long
events I I know the moment I can tell
you when the energy shifts in the room
and now I know it's going to be fun now
I know get ready cuz the Miracles are
happening it'll happen in one week you
tell me how a tumor can disappear on a
person's thyroid not one not two you
tell me how a man with a stroke who's
been paralyzed in his arm and leg that's
in his 70s paralyzed for years now
lifting his arm above his head how do
you explain that he he didn't do that
matter to matter he didn't change his
diet he didn't do physical therapy he
didn't try to have a good attitude and
think positively that was none of
that something in the field changed and
the pattern of that condition in the
field
changed so it is happening in a shorter
amount of time there is no rule
it's about the person's ability to pay
attention and to focus to be greater
than their body their environment and
time it's their sincerity it's the
engagement when they go sit down and do
it they're not doing oh man I got to do
this that's the wrong attitude nothing's
going to happen then you get there like
I'm going to connect with the Divine
this is going to be a great day I'm
going to keep my energy up I'm not
getting up until I feel like I'm
empowered that person's going to have a
rocking day they're going to have a good
day rule number four is shift your
Paradigm with Bob Proctor I had been
raised to believe that if you're going
to earn a lot of money you've got to be
really smart I knew I wasn't that smart
but I was earning a lot of money so I
knew that wasn't right
um I was raised to believe if you don't
go to school you'll never get a good job
I didn't have a good job I owned the
whole
company I couldn't figure it out do you
know it took me 9 and 1/2 years well 9
and 1/2 years later I met the man that I
showed you his name Leland Val Vandal he
um he changed my life completely he
introduced me to a concept I'm going to
introduce you to and when he did that it
was like everything I'd been studying i'
been studying a lot of
information but I'd study this book I'd
give this book to people and they didn't
change and what he did he brought
everything together for me in a
relatively short period of time now
here's a couple of things he told me if
you go back screen scunt and he said Bob
he he he pointed out he said you are a
unique individual and he said so am I so
is everybody else and he said you can
literally create your own economy you
can do that and he said the only thing
standing between you and what you want
is yourself he all about the Mind Bob he
says it's about your marvelous mind then
he started thanks God then he started to
talk to me about the mind and he said
you know it's a strange thing Bob when
we get talking about the Mind nobody's
ever seen the mind they have never seen
the mind now keep in mind that I was a
very uneducated person um when you talk
about the mind I mean I would think of
psychiatrist psychologist behavioral
scientists no he said you want to get
rid of those ideas he said the way I'm
going to explain it to you was the way
it was explained to me and he said um we
can change we can show children how the
Mind
functions and he said I'm going to show
you something here that's rather
interesting and he said Bob
understanding the mind and uh and
working in harmony with the laws
governing the mind is essential if you
really want to win in life and then he
started to tell me what a paradigm was
and he said a paradigm is a mental
program that has almost exclusive
control over our habitual behavior and
he started talk about that he said it's
a PR in your subconscious mind that
controls your behavior and the Paradigm
has almost exclusive control over our
habitual behavior and almost all of our
behavior is
Habitual nor said I want you to think
about this and I want you to think about
it we get out of bed in the morning and
uh we bang away we go we move into a
routine and if you're living with
someone else you don't mess around with
their routine because you just don't do
that we've all got got a routine and we
go into a routine and we do that day
after day and most people do it for
their whole life ear nil used used to
say most people tiptoe through life
hoping they make it safely to death it's
rather an interesting concept and the
Paradigm is the program in your
subconscious mind now I said here's the
crazy part about it Bob the people that
write this program the ones that wrote
the code for the program um they really
didn't know what they were doing think
of this for a moment I've got a computer
here it's in a phone I've got another
computer right in front of me and then
here I've got um I've got a pad and um
these are computers now there's people
write programs for these computers they
write code and they really know what
they're doing and they're very very good
and the program for me to put the slides
up here that's a program it's a
PowerPoint program and um the things
work like like a charm
well the people that are writing the
code for them are very well educated and
really understand what they're doing but
he said the people that writing the
program for the code that runs your life
they didn't know what they were doing
now most people don't even know that
they have a program think of this for a
moment how do you account for a person
going to the very best schools in the
world getting prestigious degrees then
spend the rest of their life losing how
do you account for that how do you
account for the fact that a person will
come up with degrees that'll run right
off the end of a business card and maybe
not able to get a half decent job very
insecure how do you account for that
well I'm going to tell you how there's a
part of your mind that gathers
information there's a part of your mind
when you read the book you store the
information in that part of your mind
but that part of your mind is not the
part that controls the behavior of this
thing that you're living in your body is
an instrument of your mind it is is an
instrument of your mind and it's your
body that moves into action and produces
the results you're getting rule number
five is believe your worthy with Mel
Robbins just give yourself
permission to want the things that you
want and unless you believe that you're
worthy unless that you practice love
you're never going to think that you
deserve the things that you want right
so tell the
story okay so I'm probably going to
I'll shorten it I'll shorten it so the
bottom line is is that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience that you may be able to
relate to and that is I walked in and I
immediately saw this painting hanging on
the wall and it was about the size of a
door only horizontal and it was a
Vermont landscape and I was drawn into
it immediately like I was no longer in
that restaurant I was standing in that
field I could feel that breeze I'd never
ever had an experience like that with a
painting have you ever had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean my yeah my
sense was that this is very atypical for
you very so
I kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then
I leaned back I'm suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm going to own
this painting someday it just that was
what was right there and I looked at the
price and it said like $3,000 I'm like
not today and I went back and I sat down
and that was it but the painting never
left my mind you see there's something
called the zenar effect I I always say
it wrong but it's like there's a
checklist in your brain that when you
have a moment where you're like this is
important your brain puts it on a
checklist yeah there's like a notch yes
a notch happens and now your brain as
part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high-intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember so uh bottom
line is uh I always thought about that
pain
years go by whenever somebody would say
Vermont I'd think of the painting I
don't know why I can't explain it never
wanted a painting before was not an art
student it's going to lawol like you're
out collecting art no no no and so I you
know fast forward the story 10 years and
my uh H Chris and I are are engaged and
we're going to go up to Vermont to see
the leaves and immediately I'm like we
got to go to Simon Pierce I got to show
you the painting so we pull up to the
mill and we walk in and right in front
there is Boom a painting by the same
artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh my
God it's here and we race all around the
place and it's gone and the funny thing
was and this is the way your brain works
Chris was more disappointed than I was I
literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we were
still here after 10 years I'm going to
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's going to happen
Chris I'm going to be able to buy this
like 40 years from now it's going to be
hanging in the corporate Lobby of some
building and I'm going to have to track
down the owner and pay like quadruple
the money they pay but I'm going to own
this have Mission yes so a couple years
pass and um it's my birthday I think I
was turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris
gets a couple people
to give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had I had
what 500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the
time with our first kid I should have
bought a crib or stools but for whatever
reason the zigen arch effecta takes over
and I'm like the painting so I call the
mill and I get this guy on the phone I'm
like uh you know I want to buy a kale
Shephard piece and I said could you send
me Polaroids and he's like sure and I
tell him the budget and he goes I'll
I'll send you Polaroids of some of her
smaller things MH and she's like blowing
up in the meantime right yeah she's a
very very successful Vermont landscape
artist and so
I I I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting and I describe
the painting I had seen over 10 years
ago and he said well that was way before
my time but I bet Gail will know and I'm
like Gail you know Gail he's like of
course I know Gail she like lives in in
down the road here's her number so for
two days I paced around the apartment
with 500 bucks in my pocket driving
Chris crazy because I felt like what am
I going to say to her and I must be a
weirdo I've been stalking this lady I've
been thinking about her for 10 years I
can't afford a painting you know what
who am I to buy a painting like what the
hell
so finally Chris is like would you call
her or I'm going to call her you're
driving me crazy so I call her and I
start talking a mile a minute and she
was
amazing and then um I said by the way
there is this one painting and I go and
I explain this painting there is a stand
of popler trees down the center and a
big mountain scape behind it and this
beautiful blue Vermont sky and geese
flying in formation overhead and I could
hear her thinking on the other end of
the line and she saidou know Mel I've
done so many large
scale uh paintings over the years I'd
hate to mistake the one you're talking
about but I'll tell you what what if my
husband and I meet you and Chris at the
Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll walk all
around and have lunch and I'll tell you
the stories behind every painting and if
you don't see what you like there I'll
take you back to my studio which is a
couple miles down the river and you can
look at everything I'm working on and if
you don't see anything you like there
then you can go through all my slides
and see if you can find that painting
that you saw 10 years ago and I said
deal so a month passes we go up to the
mill I walk in we meet each other she's
amazing she's like twice our age just
incredibly cool lady she's walking
around as we're walking around looking
at these paintings Rich I've got I'm
like eight months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have MH I can't afford this like
I don't I don't have this kind of money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that impostor syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down and she goes now that you're
sitting down I have something to tell
you
um she said there's only been two times
in my career as an artist that I've done
two studies of the same
piece and your painting is one of them
it's one of a
pair she knew all along she knew all
along she was playing games with you
about not knowing which painting yeah
and she said the sister piece to the one
that you saw all those years ago is
sitting in my studio right now where
it's been for the past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car and we drive
to the mill and when we walk in they in
the center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it
was one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was standing before that
painting in
1990 saying it would be mine and there I
was 11 years
later standing in front of it and then I
realized oh my God I can't
afford this and Chris walks over and
he's like what's wrong and I'm like just
promise me someday like promise me that
I don't need a a jewelry I don't need a
car like just promise me you will buy me
this thing and he kind of leans over and
goes hey Gail how much for the big one
and she said um Mel can have it for 500
bucks cuz clearly when I was making it
11 years ago I was making it for
her
yeah and so it hangs in my kitchen it's
on the back of the book um this is the
galley though right so wait is it in the
is it in I think so yeah yeah and um
it's a reminder every day that your mind
is designed to help you get what you
want I never stop believing that I could
make it happen and when you tell your
mind what's important to you there is
extraordinary
science that proves that your mind has a
live and everchanging filter a live
Network that Chang ches how it views the
world What it lets in what it blocks out
and if you program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want and rule number six the
last home before some very special bonus
Clips is control your future with Louise
Hay when we are very little we learn how
to feel about ourselves and about life
by the reactions of the adults around
us now if you lived with frightened
people or with people who were very
unhappy then you learned a lot of
negative things about yourself and about
life you may still believe
them however this is not to blame our
parents for we are all victims of
victims and they could not possibly have
taught us anything they did not know if
your mother did not know how to love
herself or your father did not not know
how to be gentle and kind then it would
be impossible for them to teach you to
love yourself or to be gentle and
kind your parents were doing the best
they could with what they had been
taught as
children I also believe that we choose
our
parents each one of us decides to
Incarnate upon this planet at particular
points in time and space
I believe we do this because we have
chosen to come here to learn a
particular lesson that will advance us
upon our spiritual evolutionary
pathway we choose our sex our color our
country and then we look around for the
particular set of parents who will
mirror the pattern we are bringing in to
work on in this
lifetime all often when we grow up we
point our fingers accusingly at our
parents and whimper you did it to me but
really we chose them because they were
perfect for what we wanted to work on
overcoming as very little children we
learn our belief systems and then we
move through life creating experiences
to match our
beliefs look back in your own life and
notice how often you have gone through
the same
experience well I believe that you
created those experiences over and over
because they mirrored something that you
believed was true about
yourself it really doesn't matter how
long we have had a problem or how big it
is or how life threatening it is the
point of power is always in the present
moment this means that what you have
experienced during your life and up to
this moment you have created by your own
thoughts and beliefs of the
past however what you are choosing to
think and believe and say today right
here and right now is creating your
future your current internal dialogue is
creating tomorrow next week next month
next year Etc
notice what you are thinking at this
moment do you want this thought to be
creating your future is it negative or
positive just notice and be
aware I'm not trying to create guilt for
anyone nor to make anyone wrong I am
making us aware of what is going on
inside of
us many of us who create illness and
disease are in fact totally out of touch
with what is going on in our minds and
in our
bodies we only notice our bodies when we
become ill or are in pain if we do not
know what is going on inside of us how
can we ever
change no matter what the problem is the
only thing we are ever dealing with is a
thought and a thought thought can be
changed all our experiences are just
outer effects of our inner
dialogue even self-hatred is only hating
a thought you have about
yourself you may have a thought that
says I'm a bad
person this thought produces a feeling
and you accept the feeling is
true however if you eliminate the
thought you don't have the
feeling thoughts can be changed change
the thought and the feeling must
go believe it or not we do choose our
thoughts we may habitually think the
same thought over and over so often that
it does not seem that we are choosing
the thought but we did make the original
choice we can refuse to think certain
thoughts
[Music]
look how often you have refused to think
a positive thought about
yourself well you can also refuse to
think a negative thought about
[Music]
yourself it seems to me that everyone on
this planet that I know or have worked
with is suffering from self-hatred and
guilt to one degree or another the more
self-hatred and guilt we have the less
our life
works we find we have an inability to
speak up for ourselves and we're always
trying to please
others or we may be angry and explosive
all the
time the less self-hatred and guilt we
have the better Our Lives work on all
levels this includes the health of the
body
too could you speak about the
neurophysiology of
forgiveness
sure think
about Frozen circuits Frozen circuits or
hardwired
circuits the more profound the insult to
the
person that is connected to a strong
emotion the more the brain freezes
circuitry the more we think about the
experience the more we fire and wire the
circuits in our brain yes or no yes and
the more we remember the event the more
we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and it you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge it's no longer conscious
that you're stuck it's now you're seeing
everybody through the lens of that
experience and everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody is
that same person you're you're
overlaying the memory of re of your
experience into reality you're not
seeing it the way it is you're seeing
that person wearing the mask of the last
person that's the lens that we're
perceiving reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion and the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still and so then the person says I'm
not that person and you say oh no I know
I just had this event in my past and I'm
sorry and then it's excusable but then
here it happens again and there's
nothing wrong with this we all do it
it's just how do we overcome it so
then you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your
brain you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
you're unfolding as nobody no one no
thing nowhere no time and the identity
and the personality is gone energy is
going to move it's got to it's going to
follow the
path you're opening your heart once it
gets to your heart it's going to make
its way all the way up and when you feel
love and compassion when you feel true
true kindness and care it's hard to hold
a grudge are you with me still yes so
then from
a quantum physics point of
view you have that person always in the
back of your mind mind right you have
the event and the memory rolling around
back there because the very thing that
you don't want to have happen you're
already preparing for emotionally are
you with me still so then from a Quantum
perspective you are actually as a
creator of reality holding yourself
hostage because of that person and you
are holding them hostage because of that
experience and you have an energetic
Bond that's connecting you to them and
you're sharing the same energy and so
then you're using each other to reaffirm
whatever that energetic agreement is are
you with me still so then when you
forgive someone it's because there's
been a strong change in your emotional
state cu the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person and so then once
you start
lowering the volume to that emotion and
the body starts liberating energy and
you're calling your energy back to you
because the lower the volume of the
emotion the less you're going to pay
attention to that person there comes a
moment where there's a snap there's a
release the energy is broken and once
it's broken now all of a sudden you free
yourself and you free them and this has
happened to me in my life that people
show up 10 years later completely
changed and
so humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because they had transformed and
and I let them go so then
forgiveness from a Quantum perspective
and a neurophysiological perspective is
just taking your attention off them
that's all it is and when you start
getting happy with
yourself and you start feeling those
elevated emotions cuz you're driving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up and you start
having energy in the center and it's
releasing 1,300 to, 1400 different
chemicals that begin to restore and
regenerate the body the body start
getting a lift of energy once it makes
its here now you're going to see that
track sending in energy to the brain the
heart acts as an amplifier to boost the
brain are you with me still so then once
the Energy starts making its way into
the brain once the heart starts to open
we've measured this with our students
they have oxytocin levels rise once you
start feeling oxytocin when you feel
more love then you feel The Grudge so
then you
think why would I want to give this up
for that person that's called
forgiveness you don't have to try to do
it it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation and ox toin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amydala the survival center of the brain
and the research is outstanding and the
first thing it does is it fits in the
same receptor sites as fear and it
lowers the volume to fear and anxiety it
shuts the lights out for aggression and
anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of
forgiveness matter to matter you can do
it but it's a takes a long time and a
lot of work and then you forgive and
then you're like I don't want to forgive
him
yeah halfway forgive
him and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand and you
know there was a woman that came to our
work
and she was raped by four men when she
was a
teenager and it was abusive and and she
had severe severe night terrors
severe uh um anxiety and panic attacks
she had cyclic mood problems she had
been to every single doctor every single
healer every single alternative
practitioner nothing changed it she came
to our event
in in um Tacoma
Washington and she hit that point where
she became everybody everyone everything
everywhere every time every place she
became the
Oneness and the and that frequency had a
message for her and it said and she was
an incredible Bliss when this
happened I sent four Angels disguised as
rapists for this
moment and that was the end of her
Terrors that was the end of her night
she couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was
isolated one moment the Divine stepped
in and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just the not just
the thought she got the energy moved
right through her body and she saw the
whole thing and that
moment is what she was waiting for
that's what the soul was waiting for now
she's healed she's healthy she's happy
and she's on with a new life she's born
my mother would love this she's born
again in the same life reborn in the
same life didn't pass through a birth
canal for it she just was born again in
the same life she got a new lease in one
instant that energy was carrying a
message and it made its way all the way
into the body and the Bliss and the joy
and the Gratitude and the love that she
felt
the message that was carried would made
total sense to her she's free one
instant to me that's true
forgiveness that's the Divine having its
way with you so learning to create our
minds the way we want is the basis of
creating the world the way we want there
is a wonderful story in the yogic
LA on a certain day a man took a walk he
went for a long
walk accidentally unaware
he walked into Paradise fortunate isn't
he he just took a walk and he landed up
in
Paradise after this long walk he felt
little
tired so he thought oh I'm tired I wish
I could rest
somewhere he looked around there there
was a nice
tree underneath which there was very
cushiony grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and
slept after a few hours he woke
[Music]
up well rested and he thought oh I'm
well rested but I'm feeling hungry I
wish I had something to
[Music]
eat and he thought about all the nice
things that he ever wanted to eat in his
life and instantly all those things
appeared in front of him you need to
understand they have the servic is like
[Music]
that hungry people don't ask questions
food came and he
ate stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to
[Music]
drink all the nice things that he ever
wanted to
drink he thought about it and all of
them just appeared in front of him
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he
drank now with a little bit of alcohol
in him you know Charles Darwin told you
all of you are monkeys your tail fell
away not me Charles Darwin told you that
you were all monkeys and your tail fell
away and then you became human yes
definitely the tail fell away but the
monkey in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as markata which means a
monkey why we are referring to the Mind
as a monkey
is what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's
unnecessary
movement and another thing about the
monkey is if I say you're monkeying
somebody what does it mean
imitation monkey and imitation have
become
synonymous so these two essential
qualities of a monkey are very much the
qualities of an unestablished mind
unnecessary
moment you don't have to learn it from
the monkey you can teach it to the
monkey and imitation is full-time job of
the
mind so when these two qualities are on
a mind is referred to as a monkey so
this monkey became active within
him he just looked around thought what
the hell is is happening here I asked
for food food
came I asked for drink drink
came there must be ghosts around
here and ghosts
came oh the ghosts have come there going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghost surrounded him and
started torturing
him then he started screaming in pain
and said oh they're going to kill me and
he died just now he said said he he's a
fortunate
being the problem is he was sitting
under a Culp OFA or a wishing
tree he asked for food food came he
asked for drink drink came he asked for
ghost ghost came he asked for torture
torture came he asked for death death
happened now don't go looking for these
kalpa rukas in the forest you can barely
find a
tree these
days
a well established mind a mind which is
in a state of Sam yukti is referred to
as a CP per
fiction if you organize your mind to a
certain level of organization it in turn
organizes the whole system your body
your emotion your energies everything
get organized in the direction once all
these four dimensions of you your
physical body your mind your emotion and
the fundamental life life energies are
organized in One Direction once you like
this anything that you wish happens
without even lifting a little finger
actually it would help to assist it with
activity but even without doing any
activity you can still manifest what you
want if you organize these four
dimensions in One Direction and keep it
unwavering in that direction for a
certain period of time right now the
problem with your mind is every moment
it is changing its direction it is like
you want to travel somewhere and every
two steps if you keep changing your
direction the question of you reaching
the destination is very remote unless it
happens by
chance so organizing our minds and in
turn organizing the whole system and
these four basic dimensions of who you
are right now in One Direction if you do
this you are a kpaa yourself anything
that you wish will
happen but right now if you look at your
lives everything that you have wished
for till now if it happens you
finished everything and everybody that
you have desired for if all of that
lands up in your house today could you
live with
that once we're empowered like this it's
very important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the
planet so what should have been a boon
we are making a curse out of
it what has brought incredible levels of
comfort and convenience to us in the
last 100 years or so
has also become a threat to our life
simply because we are not conscious
action we are in a compulsive state of
action so organizing our minds
fundamentally means moving from a
compulsive state of activity to a
conscious state of
activity you might have heard of people
for whom they asked for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
true for them generally this happens to
people who are in
faith now let's say you want to build a
house if you start thinking oh I want to
build a house to build a house I need 50
lakhs but I have only 50 rupees in my
pocket not possible not possible not
possible the moment you say not possible
you also saying I don't want it so on
one level you're creating a desire that
you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not
happen someone who has some faith in a
God or in a temple or whatever who is
Have simple-minded Faith Works only for
those people who are simple-minded
thinking people people who are too much
thinking for them it never works a
childlike person who has a simple faith
in his God or his Temple or whatever he
goes to the temple and says Shiva I want
a house I don't know how you must make
it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of
Faith now he believes sha will do it for
him and it will
happen so is Shiva going to come and
build your house no I want you to
understand God will not lift his little
finger for you what you refer to as God
is the source of
creation as a Creator he's done a
phenomenal job there's no question about
it could you think of a better creation
than this is it in anybody's imagination
to think anything better than what is
there right now so as a Creator he has
done his job wonderfully well but if you
want life to happen the way you want it
because right now the very Crux of your
happiness and your well-being is this if
at all if you're
unhappy the the only and only reason why
you're unhappy is life is not happening
the way you think it should happen
that's all it is so if life is not
happening the way you think it is it
should happen you're unhappy if life
happens the way you think it should
happen you are happy it's as simple as
that so if life has to happen the way
you think it should happen first of all
how you think with how much Focus you
think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process this possible is
something possible or not possible is
destroying
Humanity what is possible and not
possible is not your business it's
Nature's business your business is just
to strive but what you want when you
have a goal in your head it's not even a
goal it's a fantasy it's a dream when
you have a book like this you can call
it your goal book and you write out your
goals and you go through I'm just about
to take you through bit by bit stage by
stage you go back to that but you can
look at it you can touch it you can just
make it real so remember if you do not
write out your goals as a plan and write
out how to accomplish them you don't
have a goal you have a wish you have a
dream you have a Daydream if you want to
go get a pen get a nice little book like
this you can do it on your phone too you
can make a document in your
computer and be prepared to make your
goals real so let's start now get your
book pause this if you need to go and
find one create one and I want you to
pick a goal and do not even start with I
want to lose £5 I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy goals no if
you can make your goals real you might
as well make them huge big enormous
phenomenal so if you say well I want
more money that's my oh hang on a minute
hey I got $10 here there you go you go
well that's not my goal but you said I
want more money and I learned this when
I used to work with women who were
infertile that come and they go you know
what I just want to be pregnant I want
to be pregnant so bad if I was just
pregnant I go well as I look at your
notes you've been pregnant six times I
know I keep
miscarrying so being pregnant is not
your goal is it what isn't your goal to
carry to fullterm a healthy robust
bouncing baby to deliver a perfect baby
to be a great mom yeah that's my goal
why didn't you say that because you can
be pregnant and lots of times and never
have a baby all you can say my goal is
to have a perfect baby how about this my
goal is to get lots of attention for
what a nervous twitch explosive gas that
will give you attention but that's not
what you want is it nobody wants
explosive gas so let's start with a big
goal pause if you need
to take some time open your book and
write out a big goal now you can have a
career goal on whatever I'm going to
have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow in loving and
respecting each other and you can have a
health goal but I want you to pick one
only one not three not five not 10 one
goal it can be career can be Health can
be love pick one goal and then I want
you to decide why you want that goal so
much so the first thing is I have a goal
I want to have my own business that's my
goal and now you're going to go to the
next page and write out why do you want
to have your own business so much and
the more reasoned you can write out why
the more
likely you will make that goal real so
write down why write down as many whys
as you can and remember you can come
back any time to this and think oh I've
thought of another why and another why
so leave plenty of space take your time
and when you've done your wise go to
another page and write out who will
benefit from you achieving that goal of
course you will but who who will benefit
for instance if you have your own
business you will employ people who will
benefit maybe your kids will go to
private school maybe your business will
allow you to help your partner have
their business the more people who will
benefit from you you achieving your goal
the more reasons you have to achieve
that goal so write out who will benefit
from you achieving a who how and why
will they benefit you're going to buy
your mama house put your niece and
nephew through private school did you
think of your mind as like the genie in
the bottle that says your wish is my
command and I want you to understand
that every thought you think and every
word you say is a blueprint that your
mind body and psyche must make real so
when you write out your goals don't say
I wish I could be rich I long to be in a
loving relationship write it as if it's
already happening I am a millionaire I
am in a loving relation you might go
that doesn't make sense it does make
sense because your mind only works in
the present tense when you say next next
year I'll have a bikini body it doesn't
know what next year is and so you must
write your goals in the present tense I
am I always I have I do this new page is
about your
discipline how many hours a day you
going to spend working on your
goal how often are you going to come
back to this book and look at it I want
you to write out I am I always I have I
do and I want you to fill that in you
see the best goal in the world will not
work if you don't work and many people
fail at this point they write out a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and they think that's it it's
not it if you want to be madly in love
write at all the reasons why but then
you have got to put yourself in front of
the kind of a person you want to share
your life with if you want to start your
own business and you have a reason why
you also need to have the discipline to
meet people who will fund you sponsor
you joint venture with you so I want you
to really understand that the best goal
will not work if you don't work you can
have the start point but you have to
keep going many of the most successful
people ever say well you know I had a
goal Luther vandros had had a goal to be
a
rockar and people said well you're an
overnight success he would I don't think
so you know I sang Jingles for KFC for
12 years that's a long night 12 years
and people said but Luther you're
singing on television that's cool get
paid a lot of money for KFC said yeah
but it's not my goal and he stuck it out
and many people have got so close to
success and had to keep going and you
have to keep going so look at your
discipline and decide you will give more
to your goal give even more work on it
look at it write it out think about it
talk about it you must be prepared to
give so much to your goal in fact you
must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your
goal because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to reshape your future with Bob Proctor
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there see in 1990 Joel
Barker wrote a book it's called
paradigms he said to be able to shape
your future you have to be willing and
able to change her Paradigm now I had no
idea what a paradigm was and you might
ask yourself